I think I built the ultimate Claude
design skill for websites, and I'm going
to give it to you guys for completely
free. This thing helps you figure out
what type of website you're looking for,
generates you all the assets, or takes
the assets you already have, and then
creates an interactive scrolling style
of website. So, it's not just your
generic AI slop. You can see in this one
we're literally going through a journey
because this is like a travel agency
that's trying to get clients to book in
with them. Here's my original website
that I had built with Claude. It's it's
okay, right? It's nothing crazy. And
what I did is I said, "Hey, Claude, look
at my website, use this skill, and
transform it." And this is what it
created. It kept all the same copy, it
kept all the same branding and the same
feel, but it turned it into something
that's way more interactive, and it
almost like hooks you in to make you
want to keep scrolling through the rest
of the website to actually see what's to
come. It has a way more premium feel
than the way that you typically get your
websites if you're building with Claude.
So, I call this skill ScrollCraft
because the whole idea is that you're
actually having this hook in the viewer
by making the scroll correlate to
something that's going on on the actual
page. So, on top of the idea that Claude
should always be looking for
opportunities to make the scroll feel
interactive, there's also design
elements in the skill as well. Things
like spacing, typography, feel, taste,
all that kind of stuff. And what you'll
notice about the skill is it's not just
one specific template, right? Every
single one of these websites that I've
shown you guys so far comes out a little
bit different, and that's why the
interview section of this skill is so
important because it asks you what type
of website do you want, what do you want
the feel to be. It really thinks about
the user journey when they would
actually open up the site and scroll
through. It's almost like short-form
content. If you don't get hooked right
away, you're not as interested. You can
see some of these are super professional
and super editorial like this one. This
is a very like trusted feel, but it
still has a bunch of scroll animations,
and it feels more premium. It just gives
it so much more depth when there's
something else going on. Love this
little animation right here. And hopping
back over to the perfume example, I had
it generate two versions for me. So,
this is the first one. They both keep
the consistency in like the color scheme
and the vibe and the actual copy that's
trying to be communicated through. The
entire site doesn't have to be super
flashy and animated. This one was mainly
just kind of like that first hero
section. But here's another version of
it that's a little more simple at the
front because we're just zooming in a
little bit. And then we get into this
thing where it's like we're only
focusing on one thing at a time and the
user is scrolling through and the user
is in control of what they're actually
going to be looking at. And now we can
see the three different product shots,
the three different flavors, and the
call to action at the end. Anyways,
there's so many different examples that
I've generated and you can see that they
all just have different vibes and
different styles, but they all are still
unique, right? Like they're going to
make the client remember your business.
So anyways, let me quit yapping and
let's just talk about how this skill
works, how you get it, and let's do a
live example together. So real quick, if
you want to get the skill, it's
completely free. You go to my free skill
community link in the description, go to
the classroom, click on all YouTube
resources, and everything that I give
away for free ever is always in here. So
just hop in and grab the skill. And so
in this video, I'm going to be using the
CloudCode desktop. I'm also going to
assume that you have a little bit of
CloudCode knowledge. So if you're just
starting out at the complete beginning,
go ahead and watch this 6-hour course I
have or I guess it'll be up here for
non-coders. Watch a little bit of that
course, get familiar with CloudCode, and
then come back in here and build some
crazy websites. So that skill will be a
plugin that you can install or you can
actually just take the actual folders
and files and put it into your cloud,
whatever you want to do. But now you can
see if I come in here and I type scroll,
we have the ScrollCraft skill, which
says to build a premium scroll-driven
interface landing page for any business.
So whatever type of product you have or
service, you can do it in here. We saw a
ton of different examples. We saw
physical products as you can see. We saw
a personal branding website, which was
for myself. Another agency that was like
travel. So you can do a lot of different
things with this skill. So let's
actually make a real website for myself
for AI Automation Society. So right now
this is AI Automation Society's website.
We've got this nice little globe
animation up top, but then there's
nothing really too special. There's a
few pictures. We tried to make it look,
you know, at least sort of branded and
trusted, but there's nothing too
engaging at all. I mean, some of the
cards move a little bit, but let's try
to like redo this website. So I'm
looking to use this skill to redo my AI
Automation Society website. I'm looking
for this one to be premium, trusted. I'm
looking for this one to be more
editorial rather than a bunch of
different AI generated assets and not
like a a world that we'd be flying
through. I'm looking for this one to be
more premium. I'm basically just going
to start off like that because the first
part of the skill is going through sort
of like an interview process to really
understand the type of vibe you're
looking for. Because like like this one,
right? This is a bunch of AI generated
assets that creates us like this flying
world effect where we have like we're
bouncing around. This one also has AI
generated assets, but it's a bit more um
like hypie, it's a bit more energetic
with, you know, a product that we're
trying to sell, a physical product. So,
I think the vibe that I'd be looking at
for this AI automation society one is
maybe something a little bit more like
this that has like subtle animations and
subtle scroll. So, you can see we're not
starting from zero. It has our site, it
has our brand assets, and it has other
builds that we've done, and now it's
going to interview us. So, right now
let's say you have no business at all,
you don't know what you're going to
build a site for, just go ahead and do
everything with AI generated assets just
to play around with the skill to see how
it works. And the way that this skill
specifically does it is it uses key.ai.
So, if you've never used key.ai, it's
kind of like open router but for like
image and video models. You can choose
between all these different ones. So, if
I actually go to my logs real quick, you
can see some of my most recent
generations were um results that we just
used. So, this can thing, we also have
like the the phase, we have the cup, we
have all of these assets that we've been
generating for these websites, videos or
images. And all you have to do is go
into here, grab an API key, and then put
that in your environment variables of
the cloud code project, and then it'll
be able to just hit this for all of the
assets that it needs. And it will fill
in the gaps. It'll automatically create
images and then turn those images into
videos, and it will stitch the videos
together. It'll do whatever it needs to
do because the skill tells it how. But
here we are, we have some questions
coming. So, what's the scroll journey?
What does the visitor hit first and in
what order after that? So, do we want to
open with the proof receipts first like
these big stats? Do we want to start
with Nate's story? Do we want to start
with inside look? I think we want to
just start up top with the receipts,
that's what it recommended. Then it asks
what must the visitor believe by the
end, one sentence not a feature list.
And so what I'm actually going to do is
kind of like put in a mission statement
here. So I'm just going to paste in what
we say. Go ahead and hit next. What real
assets do you have? This decides how
much gets generated versus graded from
what you own. Photos of us, and events,
community screenshots, workflows. What
do we have and what does it need to go
generate? Just use the pictures that are
already in there. So like there's one
image of me speaking. There is also an
image of like all of us at one of our
events. It's like it looks kind of like
a Zoom call, but those are the only two
images I gave you besides the one at the
bottom that says meet our founder and
the merch image. So those are the images
you should work with. But actually it'd
be cool if you generated a few images of
like like if you generated images that
weren't necessarily photorealistic, but
they were sort of like looking at
educational environments. So maybe like
a nice style of I'm blanking on what the
style would be called. I guess maybe I'm
thinking this like low poly geometric. I
guess we'll try that. Like a
minimalistic geometric low poly human
figures. You know, if there were maybe
scenes that go along with the
certification or the events or AIS Plus.
Like people having wins, people teaching
each other, people working together.
Just keep it minimal and make it match
the color scheme and the brand
guidelines of AIS. But just something
else to give it a little bit of flavor
here that we can sync up with some
scrolls. Finally it says one thing this
site should do that no sites you've seen
does. This becomes the signature move.
Every claim has a receipt. Nothing on
the page is asserted without a source.
Yeah, I guess we'll go with that one for
now and hit submit. So that's where you
can get really really specific and the
better idea you have of like what you
want, feel free to put that in there.
But if you don't have an idea, that's
the beauty of this skill is it knows a
bunch of taste as far as like what makes
good scroll animations. As you saw all
those examples I showed you, there were
so many different things. Like here's
one I didn't love, but this one has at
the end like some really cool things
where it looks like um
like flight cards, right? It looks like
these departure cards and the
destinations and we see this sinking to
the scroll. So really what's important
to me is that everything on the site,
basically, the user is in control with
their mouse because they're basically
controlling what's happening and they
can go backwards, they can go forwards.
And whether that be controlling like
scrolling images like that or actually
just having like numbers fade in or
appear like that or this image kind of
like fades out as well. It's really just
about that idea of the scroll sinking to
something. Few more questions here.
Where should this page feel calm and
where should it feel intense? I'm just
going to go through some of these other
design questions and then um I'll check
in with you guys when anything
interesting's happening. Lately I've
been finding that you can really
instruct AI models a little bit more
emotionally than you used to in the
past. Like I'm telling this thing what I
want it to feel like and what I want the
motivation to be and it I really have it
thinking about if it was the user and
clicking through and scrolling through,
what would it feel and how do we sort of
like manipulate that emotion as much as
we can. But anyways, this thing is
building now. I will check back in with
you guys when we have something to look
at. One thing I want to call out here,
after it started generating these images
and stuff with key.ai, it started to
build a website and now that it's
building it, it does verification. So it
says now the part the harness can't
judge, zooming into keyframes. So it's
literally taking screenshots of the site
and it's going to investigate and
inspect them to make sure that nothing
is off and nothing is wrong. And so
that's how hopefully it's able to give
us something on the first shot that's a
lot better than if it didn't do this
verification pass. So I just wanted to
call that out. That should be going on
in the background. And that's why it's
so important to watch Claude as it's
working. You get a feel for how the
harness actually behaves. Okay, so here
we are. This thing has finished up. It
took about 30 minutes, I believe, and we
have right here a screenshot that
basically goes through the flow. So it
kind of went through the scroll itself
to see what the vibe is like. So let's
click in. I haven't looked at this yet.
Okay, so right off the bat it definitely
feels kind of like that professional,
almost like a report sort of vibe. It's
very editorial in that way. It's very
professional. First glance though it
looks pretty boring. So hopefully as we
start to scroll through, we get some
cool stuff going on. We have live data,
so it actually went ahead and pulled
live numbers right now. This is like as
of today. This, I believe, also, if I go
to my free school real quick, um 441.5.
This is literally as of today. So, it
pulled up literally fresh numbers. We've
got preparing as many people as possible
for a new way of working. AI is
reshaping how work is done. Oh,
interesting. Look at this. I just
noticed this. I'm going to refresh. It
says right now sourced zero out of nine.
So, on the left-hand side, we have
sources. As I scroll down, we start to
unlock new sources. So, that's kind of
cool. Um okay, so now we have switched
into sort of like a dark mode. It says
it stopped being a room a long time ago,
and we're kind of growing the members,
and we're growing the global presence,
which I really like. Although, I think
that this animation goes a little too
quick. Like on a typical scroll, that's
too fast. So, we can have it slow that
down, which I'll show you guys. We want
to slow this down, but that's very nice.
I like that graphic. We have exhibit A,
the room on an ordinary Tuesday. It's
the live call right here. We have some
testimonials right here, Glenn, Casper,
and Amy. Very, very cool. And all three
of those people were actually on this
call, too, Glenn, Casper, and Amy. I
love that. As we keep going down, we've
got four quarters on a public
leaderboard. Wait a minute. Okay, so it
literally went I don't know where I kept
these, but it went and found these
screenshots because this info is not on
the original site. We don't have these
screenshots anywhere. So, it had to go
find those somewhere. It found these
leaderboard pictures and put them in
here for our four out of four school
game wins in 2025. And then we have
right here
um exhibit F, which is the AS Plus
classroom. Okay, so we have a sort of
like a horizontal scroll coming along
there. We've got six out of nine
sources. The founder, he was not a
developer when he started, graduated
from University of Iowa. Cool. It's got
this picture. Nice. Um we will have to
fix this caption though cuz that was not
AIS Live. That was Africa AI. So,
there's a few things that we'll want to
fix and touch up, but here is a video
that we've got, the sort of the
geometric low poly. This is for the
certification, so it's like they're
teaching. Very cool. Um I might need to
fix some of this copy. Where does this
button link? Okay, that links to our
free school. We'll have to change some
of the stuff up. Um
everything this page just claimed. What
is this?
Oh, okay. So, this kind of runs through
those nine sources. I don't know if I
love that, but I don't know, kind of
cool. We have the free community right
here, and then we have AIS Plus, which
takes us to AIS Plus. Okay, very cool.
So, I believe that we have our merch
there. We have the certification once
again, and then that's basically the
end. Cool. So, this is obviously a very
different vibe than the original AIS
website. It's a different vibe, but it
has similar feel. You can tell it's
still the same brand, it's still the
same
um guidelines, right? So, now it's just
a matter of we can get pretty nitpicky
here. What are the little little things
that we don't like, and what are the
little things that we want to have
changed about the site? But overall, I
think that this is a very unique site.
Haven't really seen many websites like
this. All right, so I've got a little
bit of feedback here about the site.
First of all, I want to say I think you
did a good job. You got creative, and
you took in my feedback, which was good.
I like how you went and pulled live
numbers. That was really nice. So, as
far as the hero section, it's a little
bland when someone first loads up the
page. It's a little bit brand bland, and
it doesn't feel
I don't know, it doesn't feel very
premium. So, maybe you can add a little
bit of depth here, or maybe just some I
don't know, do something to this hero
section, because that's like where we
want to hook in the audience. Now, I
really like this first part about the
reach. I really like the scroll
animation with the the globe filling up.
I feel like that feels very on brand. It
shows the members growing. Although, it
scrolls too fast. So, if you could slow
this down significantly, so the users
can actually scroll and realize what's
going on, that would be great. Um as we
continue to go down here, I like exhibit
A. I like the room about the community.
I like the testimonials here. I think
that's good for now. I think maybe if
you could just add some more
I don't know, like it just feels a
little bit bland. I like how we get into
exhibits B through F. I like the
sideways scroll, but it just once again
feels a little bit bland, and I think
that you can work in some elements here
to make this just feel more premium.
Um there's nothing special about the
founder section. Maybe we have something
like a scroll animation here as well,
just to make it less bland. Um I like
this little animation for the
certification, but it feels like it
doesn't quite last long enough. Maybe
you could slow it down or make that a
little more exaggerated. Also, the link
for the certification, if you could grab
the actual link that's linked in the
main site, on the main AIS site, the
certification link takes you to like a
waiting list, I believe. So, to reserve
your place, yeah, it should take you to
a waiting list. So, grab that link and
make sure that that's on the actual site
here that you're building for us. And
honestly, I don't love the register.
Let's just get rid of that section. I
like the idea you had with like making
this scrolling and adding more
animations and making this interactive,
but I don't like the register, so you
can get rid of that. And yeah, I think
the rest at the moment is fine. Let's
just kind of clean up some of the stuff.
Okay. So, I'm going to shoot this off,
we'll give you this feedback, and I will
check in with you guys when we get the
stuff back. Okay, so next version came
back. We can see that we have it open on
our local host. It says the register is
gone. The globe got slowed down a little
bit. A new hero section, so now it's a
magazine cover. So, we'll see what that
looks like. And everything else that we
wanted has been changed. So, let us go
back over here and open up this link,
and we see, okay, nice. I like how that
kind of came in. If I go give it this a
refresh, you can see how that scrolls
in. I like that. Um we have a little
picture of me over here, and we have
same copy.
Same feel. Nice little blue
um highlight on the mouse. I might be a
little too much, but anyways. This Okay,
cool. This is scrolling a lot slower
now, so we're able to sort of watch the
numbers go up. We're see we're sort of
able to watch the map kind of get taken
over by these blue dots and all these
connections. I really like that
animation. I think that's really cool.
We can see here the room on an ordinary
Tuesday. There's no animation to this
part. Maybe we should have like this
image kind of like reveal, or we should
have the text come through as if it was
being typed or something. We could
easily add that fix. We go down to this
part. It added like these little colors
behind these these cards are kind of
like dynamic if we put the mouse over it
and we hover.
Um this one scrolls in nice. So, that's
kind of what I want to do to
um
maybe up here. I want to have it scroll
in almost like a typewriter. And then we
have the coursework is not a credential.
Oh, nice. So it actually changed all
this copy as well. It made this more
specific to the actual cohort and then
this links to the right spot, okay? Very
cool. So as you can see the register is
now gone as well. So all the changes
that we asked for have been completed.
So what I wanted to highlight here is
that
I haven't yet created an example that
looked like this. And that's what I
think is so cool about the skill that I
built is that it utilizes design
principles, but it's not going to give
you a template. It's still going to very
much give you something that's unique to
the way that you describe, you know, the
emotions and the journey and the goals
of your business or whatever wherever
you're making the website for. And by
the way, I did have it regenerate real
quick with this coming in more like a
typewriter effect. So I think that's a
lot cleaner. You can see it did a really
cool animation here where it literally
makes each of their faces come in, each
of the screens one at a time. So that's
super slick and I love that. It You can
see it has a bit of a bug when you have
to reload like that, but otherwise it
comes in pretty clean. I like that a
lot. So anyways, guys, just remember if
you want to download the skill, go to my
free school community. It will be linked
in here with a post. It'll also be in
the classroom, all YouTube resources, AI
skills. You can find it many places in
here, but go check out the skill if you
want to build some sites like this. But
that is going to do it for today. So if
you guys enjoyed and learned something
new, please give it a like. It helps me
out a ton. And as always, I appreciate
you guys making it to the end of the
video. I'll see you on the next one.
Thanks, everyone.